youtube の動画には
コメント欄がある youtube 上のいろんな動画に様々なコメントがあるが最近
はよく
コメントの中での検挙が見かけられる
ああああああ
持っ
このコメントが
実際に人間だったら
どうなってるんだ
私は
想像してみた
始めきょう誕生日なんだ
祝ってくれ頼む狙うなおめでとう
始めじゃないけどおめでとうどこめでとうみんな岩へとは言ってるけど
高評価しのか言ってないぞまた式の誕生日やったおめでとう
止めると所長むーちゃんは二社長クソワロときっと米菓子にとってとても嬉しい誕生日
になったよ
ユースです
私は誕生日でもいいけどお前が7みんな
ありがとうし年初めありがとう
お兄ちゃん peace b yeah
いきなり使えって言われてもねぇ
アカウント作る前にお母さんに曲もらったん
小学生は youtube なんかでアカウントを作っちゃダメだよ
感じ上なの忘れてた
お母さんに読んでもらってね
やったねそういう煽り方もよっぽど小学生みたいだ
を自分はあさって誕生日なんだよあらかわいっ
テロップていっ
4月です
where
おめでとうそんなコメントで編集もらおうとしているのか
鴨庄ワロタって言っされてしまうよみなさーん登録者 by ぷに目指せ
動画って覚えてます先輩にゴキブリぶちまけたりしますぜひ見にきてくだサーイしね
うそ私も今日は誕生日ですあベネター
暴言しか言えない
超学生は rom ってなさいおめでとうです何かいいことあるといいですね
ありがとうございます最近こういうの多いよおめでとう
はっぴーばーすでよかったらチャンネル登録お願いしますおめでとうございます私はと
少して誕生日
ワーク work
おねえでももう誕生日終わっちゃうねめでとうございます確かにただのか魔女はなんだ
おめでとうこういうのは近しない方がいいやただのかマツダからなんと
手前ルナねんオメガ[ __ ]よお前キモいよ
カーマ釣果よ気にしないでねはじめじゃないけど
日にちが変わる前におめでとう
それのシゲしか言えないんですよこの人は
おめでとう上でパワーまずでエデト酸 line とかツイッターでやるよ
ここは動画のコメントをするところだ
おめでとうとか言ってるやつらもうそんなこと言うから
ごめんね氏がつけあがるんだなんかごめんなさでも始め本人もめでとうって言ってたよ
俺さぁハゲ小学生はアカウント作っちゃダメなんだよ
明日学校なんだろね時計あはじめ本人から何かしらコメント貰えるのは嬉しいけど
あを開き padi
たこういうことチャンネル登録よろしくねー
me
バッハ